à la campagne et dans les zones
périurbaines orongeurs cause de plus en
plus de maux de tête le castor certains
ils sont nomment l'architecte de la
biodiversité parce qu'en érigeant des
barrages et en inondant des terres il
arrive à créer à lui seul tout un
écosystème sauf que sa population a
explosé si bien qu'aujourd'hui plusieurs
le considèrent comme nuisibles
[Musique]
nous l'an prochain a rapporté à ce
niveau-là
parce qu'il était bouché mais c'était
vraiment une hutte de castor
[Musique]
Dominique côté produit du soya et du
maïs sur sa terre de 20 hectares
[Musique]
c'est sûr qu'on a récolté on a brisé
terrain en récoltant parce que c'était
mou normalement c'est sec
cette année des petits visiteurs ont
décidé d'ouvrir un chantier dans ce
ruisseau qui borde sa terre
[Musique]
les deux autoroutes on fait trois
barrages là
il y a pas près 8 à 10 pieds d'eau de
plus chez nous toutes mes drains sont
dans l'eau les rigoles sont toutes
plaines là si je laisse à lui-même tout
l'hiver mais rien fonctionne l'année
prochaine on sera pas capables cultiver
ici
[Musique]
les castors ont créé sept barrages en
tout sur une distance d'environ 200
mètres dans le ruisseau
incluant cette section du même cours
d'eau sous l'emprise de l'autoroute
j'ai fait un petit trou juste pour faire
baisser le niveau d'eau un peu puis à
chaque fois que je revenais c'était
bouché
dit le castor construit ses amours
seulement de branches en travers un
cours d'eau c'est pour créer un étang
qui lui permet de se protéger des
prédateurs en plus d'y accumuler ses
provisions
[Musique]
s'il y avait une famille là établi avec
des jeunes les dégâts seraient plus
considérables
moment où il y a d'autres castors à
proximité ils vont se mutiler ils vont
tellement se battre qui vont s'infiger
des bruits de blessures souvent
mortelles mais il faut contrôler ceux
qui causent des troupes c'est une bonne
place le bord le barrage principal le
Yéti c'est lui qui retient l'eau au
complet dans toute la calvette là-bas
puis non seulement ça tragit
l'infrastructure mais ça va être un
danger si l'eau va déborder sur la
chaussée
[Musique]
dorsale
les trappeurs doivent s'assurer que
chaque castor a battu soit récupérée
pour la mise en valeur de sa peau et de
certains de ses organes
la fourrure oui a vaut moins cher
qu'avant mais les glandes vont être
vendues la peau va être vendue on
connaît des personnes qui aiment la
chair de castors qui vont le consommer
en tout deux castors adultes ont été
capturés par les trappeurs un jeune
couple qui aurait fait à lui seul tout
ce travail
un chantier qui loin des humains serait
aussi devenu un habitat pour d'autres
espèces comme les tortues les
grenouilles et certains oiseaux
[Musique]
des experts du milieu phonique planche
déjà sur des moyens de prévention comme
des pré barrages pour mieux contrôler
les niveaux d'eau dans l'habitat du
castor un castor là
si on le contrôle intelligemment avec
des pré-barrages des endroits pour prier
avec du piégeage sélectif et des
endroits où c'est nécessaire moi je
pense que c'est comme ça qu'on va faire
un bon travail
[Musique]